[Music]
you're not from here are you
[Music]
from this world no neither am i
there are multiple worlds up there and
people will be looking for her
not all of them could i found her
[Music]
these troubled times call for the
magisterium to take control
this word keep her safe this knife could
cut between worlds
everyone's connected lyra how do you
know about me
you have something important to do
the time has come to act
i believe we have no choice
people are afraid of things they don't
understand
these are strange new times
[Music]
so
[Music]
there's an old native american proverb
that says
inside every person there are two bears
forever locked in combat for your soul
one bear is all things good compassion
love trust the other
is all things evil fear
shame and self-destruction
what's happening
don't let go of my head
what's happening here hide here
i have to go help them no no dad please
please don't leave me alone danny i have
to go back
stay here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all of you have killed someone
if you weren't here you've been present
or worse and your mutants
are dangerous
we know
[Music]
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it
ooh scary
what are you doing you've got to get
better someday
stephen bear let's play okay
can you feel it ancient magic
resides all around us ours
is not the only universe there are
realms
beyond it underneath it
a myriad of parallel dimensions
hey did you steal one of my digestives
no
welcome truth seekers to the truth
seekers channel
good luck guys we're on the cusp of
something here
a gateway between worlds
i'll see you on the other side
careful i've been a paranormal
investigator for 20 years
i took it from him hello
[Music]
what have you done today
to earn your place in this crowded world
utopia is a story about a rogue
scientist
who created biological warfare
they have no idea what the end of the
world is going to bring
french cut string beans aren't going to
save anybody
everything in utopia is real
basement scientist inserts himself in a
viral pandemic
you were told not to raise interest
things are getting dangerous
it shouldn't be long now we all have our
purpose
this is yours
ring
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
roger what are you doing
[Music]
what's that book you've been reading
about
[Music]
it's about heroes who get to go on
adventures
defeat the monster and save the day
a little boy from the south side of
chicago the only tourists get to do that
it's about my father and the secret
birthright that's been kept from us
you're going after it we're gonna near
the car
this is family business and family stay
together
i'm scared for myself just because they
don't want you here
doesn't mean you're not supposed to be
you gotta get away
this is an invitation to unmitigated
power
what in the hell did i go wrong with you
boy i told you to stay away from that
damn place
there's something here just trying to
get out
[Music]
everything was where and as it should be
from god to man
to creature
what's surrounded by monsters
[Music]
this legacy belongs to our family we
gotta face this new world
instinct
[Music]
this is our family story
[Music]
[Music]
shadows
[Music]
you